bienvenue dans des bas sur France 24 la
guerre en Ukraine au centre du G20 à
Bali fort de la libération de Kerson
volody mirzelinski s'est exprimée en
visioconférence face aux représentants
des puissances économiques mondiales en
l'absence de Vladimir Poutine
représentée au sommet par son chef de la
diplomatie sergueil lavrof le président
ukrainien a lancé qu'il était convaincu
qu'il fallait que la guerre s'arrête et
il a proposé 10 conditions pour parler
avec les russes dont le retour à
l'intégrité territoriale des conditions
inacceptables pour les Russes qui
bombardent de Kiev et carquish
aujourd'hui les Occidentaux voudraient
que le communiquer final évoque le mot
guerre pour caractériser le conflit en
Ukraine alors que la Russie parle
toujours d'une opération spéciale les
pays émergents comme la Chine l'Inde ou
l'Afrique du Sud reste prudent et plaide
pour l'apaisement la question de la
prolongation de l'accord sur les
céréales ukrainiennes qui prend fin
vendredi se pose pour les lumières
Zelenski s'est dit favorable à ce qu'il
soit prolongé indéfiniment Emmanuel
Macron a vous montrer Paul Kagame ou
encore Macky Sall présent au sommet pour
évoquer la crise alimentaire conséquence
de cette guerre en Ukraine alors que les
frappes russes ont repris à Kiev
aujourd'hui le G20 pourrait-il être un
point de départ de discussion pour la
paix en Ukraine la Russie est-elle de
plus en plus isolée sur la scène
internationale ou le hiatus antioxydanto
et le reste de la planète reste-t-il
béant un accord pérenne sur les céréales
pourraient-ils voir le jour et bien on
posera toutes ces questions à nos
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés les navoloshin bonsoir Elena
ancienne correspondante de France 24 en
Russie chroniqueuse de vue de Russie
c'est tous les vendredis à 18h40 sur
France 24 bienvenue Helena en face de
vous Francis la loupe aux bonsoir
journaliste indépendant éditorialiste
enseignant géopolitique auteur du blues
démocratique
1990-2020 et c'est chez cartala
bienvenue Francis laloupeau nous avons
également avec nous Thomas Friant
bonsoir fondateur et directeur général
de l'Institut open diplomatie bienvenue
et puis Jean Maurice Ripert bonsoir
ancienne ambassadeur en Russie en Chine
et à l'ONU bienvenue à vous voilà ski a
demandé au chef d'État et chef de
gouvernement de ne pas faire confiance à
la Russie simping et Joe Biden ont
rejeté tout recours à l'arme nucléaire
en Ukraine à la suite de leur entrevue
au G20 Emmanuel Macron a demandé à si
Jinping de faire pression sur la Russie
pour qu'elle revienne à la table des
négociations l'Ukraine vous l'avait
compris est au cœur du G20 semble
Vladimir Poutine mais le chef de la
diplomatie russe Sergueï labroff a dit
qu'il jugeait irréaliste les conditions
de Kiev on fait le point de cette
journée d'abord avec Alice brogna
c'est le premier sommet du G20 depuis le
début de la guerre en Ukraine un sujet
qui a d'emblé éclipsé tous les autres
avec dès l'ouverture un message vidéo du
président Hélène ski
la Russie doit retirer toutes ces
troupes formation armées du territoire
ukrainien le contrôle de l'Ukraine sur
toutes les sections de notre frontière
avec la Russie doit être rétablie cela
permettra une cessation complétée réelle
des hostilités
ukrainien a listé les 10 conditions
essentielles selon lui pour entamer des
pourparer de paix des conditions
rejetées par la Russie représentés en
l'absence de Vladimir Poutine par son
chef de la diplomatie Sergueï lavrof
tous les problèmes proviennent de la
partie ukrainienne qui refuse
catégoriquement des négociations et
avance des revendications manifestement
irréalistes et inadaptés à la situation
[Musique]
mais tout au long de la journée la
pression des Occidentaux s'est accentuée
sur la Russie
on présence du ministre russe des
Affaires étrangères nous avons souligné
l’illégalité la nature barbare de la
guerre de la Russie et son impact
dévastateur sur les populations du monde
les
Occidentaux veulent faire adopter un
communiqué final déclarons que la
plupart des membres du G20 condamnent
l'invasion russe en Ukraine il cherche
pour se faire à rallier le soutien
d'autres pays notamment de la Chine qui
n'a toujours pas condamné l'invasion
russe mais appel à un cessez le feu
autre sujet d'inquiétude pour les États
membres l'accord sur les exportations de
céréales ukrainiennes qui arrivent à
échéance vendredi et dont la Russie n'a
pas indiqué si elle le prolongerait
je commence par vous bien sûr parce que
vous êtes le diplomate de ce plateau
est-ce que vous pensez que ce G20 peut
être une sorte de départ de discussions
entre craignant et russes en tout cas de
points sur des conditions de paix entre
les deux pays
il aurait pu il aurait pu vous parlez
déjà au PC je le crains je le crainte
parce que quelque soit la bonne volonté
de tous ceux qui s'érigent en médiateur
ou qui expliquent qu'il faut que la
Russie retourne à la table des
négociations je ne comprends pas
d'ailleurs très bien ce que ça veut dire
pour être honnête avec vous parce que
retourner veut dire qu'il y en a déjà
une il n'y en a pas eu il y a une guerre
imposée à l'Ukraine par la Russie ce qui
n'est pas tout à fait la même chose mais
donc bon il y a beaucoup de gens qui qui
aimeraient que les choses s'arrêtent
évidemment on peut tous espérer qu'un
cesser le feu permettrait qu'il n'y ait
plus de victimes c'est différent de
négociations c'est différent de
discussions
comme il l'a fait
il y en avait d'autres au début de la
guerre il avait lui-même déjà il s'était
prononcé pour pour dénégociations mais
mon point de suivant Vladimir Poutine
n'est pas au G20 pourquoi
pour négocier si l'Ukraine l'avenir
l'Ukraine doit être négocié et que les
Russes considèrent que c'est un problème
russe alors il devrait être là
aujourd'hui alors que le président
zellinski a évoqué ses conditions pour
des négociations des discussions les
Russes sont décidés de bombarder
vif car kiffe et
essentiellement des civils d'ailleurs
c'est toujours une guerre contre les
civils des infrastructures troisièmement
monsieur pescoff le bien connu
porte-parole du problème a déclaré hier
ou à rappeler hier en réponse aux
présences zelinsky que malgré la reprise
de Carson par l'Ukraine Kerson resté
russe donc je ne vois pas très bien
là-dedans ou serait les moindres signaux
qu'enverrai les Russes pour être faire
état de disponibilité à négocier donc je
crains malheureusement que là nous
prenions un peu nos rêves pour des
réalités
tout de même en position de force après
la reprise de Carson oui je rejoins
complètement ce que vient de dire
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur on a vu une sorte
de réaction de la part de la Russie
suite à ce discours de 20 minutes de
volodingski devant le G20 c'était
évidemment une réaction de colère il n'y
avait pas de frappe de telle intensité
depuis les frappes qui ont suivi
l'attaque contre le pont de Crimée c'est
à dire sur tout le territoire ukrainien
il y a aussi d'autres villes qui ont été
touchés aujourd'hui par ces frappes
quasiment toute l'infrastructure
énergétique de l'Ukraine aujourd'hui a
été frappé donc c'était vraiment massif
et c'était clairement une réaction à ce
discours de Vlody mirzelens qui est où
je vainque était presque un discours
déjà d'après-guerre et Zelenski donc le
président ukrainien a dit il n'y aura
pas de mix 3 pourquoi parce que Minsk 1
et 1002 vous en étiez Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur vous avez assisté à sa
négociations c'était des négociations où
la réussir arriver en disant on n'est
pas parti du conflit et à ce moment là
la France l'Allemagne tentait de le
ramener à la raison tenter d'essayer
d'insinuer un petit peu de réalité dans
ces négociations
sur le fait que il faut que la Crimée
ski est complètement revenu sur même ses
tentatives de de de enfin cette base en
tout cas pour pour un accord de paix
entre la Russie et l'Ukraine dans la
guerre en Ukraine aujourd'hui pour vous
dire il n'y a plus de compromis possible
surtout après la reprise de Carson pour
lui il parle déjà comme si la victoire
était acquise et aujourd'hui il veut
reconquérir la Crimée et le plan encore
une fois qu'il a présenté aujourd'hui en
10 points c'est déjà un plan
d'après-guerre ce n'est pas un plan qui
est aujourd'hui à l'heure où l'on parle
comme si la guerre donc il y avait quand
même une idée derrière la tête oui
exactement parce qu'il ne négocie pas
avec la Russie il négocie avec la
communauté internationale ce n'était pas
des conditions qui étaient là pour la
Russie c'était des conditions pour les
occidentaux pour qu'ils isolent plus
encore et finalement la Russie de toute
possibilité même de futurs attaques et
il a parlé d'ailleurs pour terminer
d'instaurer un tribunal international
pour les crimes commis par la Russie en
Ukraine donc il est déjà dans le temps
d'après il est dans le temps de d'après
non pas avec les Russes ça c'est fini il
est dans le temps d'après avec les
Occidentaux alors les Occidentaux et le
reste du monde c'est à dire ces pays
émergents Francis la loupeaux est-ce que
la Russie est isolée aujourd'hui de
assez internationale on n'a pas vu de
condamnation claire la Chine ne l'a pas
condamné clairement même s'il y a eu des
discussions donc entre Joe Biden et si
Jean Ping pour l'instant on voit une
Afrique du Sud qui a priori reste aussi
silencieuse l'Inde reste toujours
prudente donc on sent bien est-ce qu'il
y a toujours ce hiatus entre les
Occidentaux et ses pays émergents au G20
ou est-ce que les frappes d'aujourd'hui
vont faire basculer un peu les pays
émergents vers la position occidentale
les pays qui concerne aujourd'hui une
sorte de neutralité notamment les pays
africains
d'abord avant tout d'une forme de
prudence et concerne une distance en
fait politique vis-à-vis de ce qu'on
peut considérer comme le protagonistes
de conflit c'est à dire la réussite d'un
côté qui a décidé donc de déclarer la
guerre à l'Occident et se dit dans les
coulisses dans les pays africains que en
fait du manège général le pays qui ont
choisi je dirais une forme de neutralité
vis-à-vis de ce conflit soit surtout
avant tout ne pas devenir des variables
des variables d'ajustement en fait d'un
conflit qui considère comme conflit qui
aurait totalement étranger avait
relativement étranger puisque il y a
l'impact sur eux est tout de même très
fort donc la crise alimentaire
avec la crise avec la crise alimentaire
vous avez remarqué quand même que voilà
pendant les votes sans vote de la
semaine générale de l'ONU les pays
africains qui ont marqué cette position
de neutralité sont à peu près une
vingtaine la MA des pays africains ont
quand même de telle manière condamnés
l'invasion de l'Ukraine n'a pas pas
de réfractaires
ils ne veulent pas justement condamner
qui ne condamne pas mais qui n'apporte
pas non plus un soutien franc et massif
la Russie parce que vous avez remarqué
que de l'Afrique à la Chine même ce que
ce qu'on considère que ceux qui que l'on
considère comme étant des soutiens
putatifs de la Russie je pense à la
Chine et à l'Inde voilà les pays
africains qui se cantonnent à une forme
de neutralité aucun de ces pays ne
justifie et la porte le soutien aux
motif de la guerre il y a peut-être
effectivement une forme de neutralité
une forme de distance de prudence mais
de la Chine au Mali en passant par la
Centrafrique ou encore l'Inde aucun de
ces pays n'apporte un soutien clairement
affirmé au motif de la guerre tel que
l'on sait par Bluetooth
hiatus au G20 alors je vais rappeler
tout de même que le G20 inclus donc les
pays émergents les fameux bricks la
Chine le Brésil l'Afrique du Sud dont on
a parlé il y a aussi la présence de Paul
Kagame à ce G20 il y a également un
Macky Sall est-ce que la Russie s'isole
de plus en plus ou pas non seulement la
réussite isole de façon générale et y
compris par les actes qu'elle a commis
aujourd'hui les bombardements sur des
civils qui continuent de façonner son
isolement mais en plus de ça elle est
isolée elle est isolée de deux manières
elle est isolée par
ce format absolument exceptionnel du G20
il faut le souligner le G20 n'est pas
une n'est pas une organisation
internationale c'est un club de leader
et ça n'est pas une organisation n'est
pas un club au moment desquels les
crises d'ordre politique comme
militaires n'ont jamais été discutés ça
a toujours été une instance de gestion
de ce qu'on appelle la gouvernance
économique mondiale c'est-à-dire en gros
l'instabilité financière le commerce
international etc donc là une rupture
historique dans la vie du G20 à ce
moment où zellinski qui n'est pas invité
formellement en tant que leader à être
présent s'exprime au début pour mettre
sur la table ce qui devait être le tabou
de ce sommet et qui explique l'absence
du président Poutine et c'est très
important pourquoi parce que l'Indonésie
a tout fait pour ménager la chèvre et le
chou
en proposant un agenda qui devait
permettre de traiter des conséquences de
la guerre l'inflation la crise
énergétique l'insécurité alimentaire et
évidemment l'incapacité du système
immunitaire en hypertension à traiter
les la continuité de la crise sanitaire
qui quand même continuer à faire des
millions de morts
tout en tenant compte du fait que ce G20
composé de trois blocs le blocs de
l'Occident qui a condamné et sanctionné
la Russie le bloc qui a condamné mais
qui n'a jamais sanctionné la Russie on
compte là-dedans la Turquie le Brésil le
Mexique l'argent dit de l'Arabie
Saoudite et le blog des opportunistes
c'est comme ça que je les appelle qui
exploitent les circonstances qui n'ont
ni condamné ni sanctionné la Chine
l'Inde l'Afrique du Sud qui était plutôt
que de c'est majeure parce que
de fait on devait parler d'économie
mondiale et en fait c'est la
géopolitique qui est revenue au poney
prend premier plan et ça ça c'est
ce qui va isoler des facto Poutine qui
n'a rien à opposer à la situation
puisqu'il n'est même pas présent et que
aucun leader si on regarde sur Twitter
ne s'affiche à côté de la voix vous
pouvez prendre n'importe quel leader du
G20 vous trouvez personne à côté de la
broff sur les réseaux sociaux au G19 oui
j'ai 19 en disant la Russie n'est pas là
donc c'est j'ai 19 et pas le G20 vous
voulez réagir également ses pair deux
tranches par rapport à ce qui a été dit
sur l'isolement d'abord par rapport à au
discours zenitski il s'adressait au G20
pour leur dire aidez-moi il s'adressait
aussi au G20 pour leur dire ne me forcez
pas la main j'ai fixé des conditions
c'est moi qui déciderai à quel moment
l'Ukraine devra négocier si elle doit
négocier et je pense que c'est sage il
est sage de s'en rappeler on peut
discuter à l'infini pour savoir s'il
faut des négociations c'est quand même à
lui de décider sur l'histoire de
l'isolement quand même excusez-moi 141
pays ont condamné la Russie aux Nations
unies au début de la guerre il n'y en a
eu que quatre pour le soutenu pour la
soutenir donc dont la Corée du Nord je
vous le rappelle grande démocratie et
l'Erythrée bien il y a eu hier un vote
aux Nations Unies sur la CROUS ce matin
je ne sais plus sur la création d'un
fond d'un création d'un mécanisme pour
réparer les dommages de guerre auprès
des Russes il a été approuvé par 93 pays
c'est-à-dire encore plus de la moitié
donc moi je veux quand Macky Sall le
président du Sénégal est allé au nom de
l'Union africaine à Moscou pour dire
vous ne pouvez pas lancer bloquer les
les exportations de céréales à dinde
finitum parce que vous allez affamer le
monde Poutine a été obligé de céder
c'était une belle preuve de
l'indépendance de l'Afrique par rapport
à ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure qui ne
condamne pas ne soutient pas mais qui
commence à faire entendre sa voix de mon
point de vue pardon un tout petit point
encore sur la Cour pénale internationale
le procureur de la Cour Pénale intern
national est déjà au travail depuis 10
mois pour enquêter sur les crimes de
guerre
il est représenté par ce chef de la
diplomatie russe qu'on connaît bien
Sergueï lavrof alors un petit événement
aujourd'hui puisque EPI donc la société
de presse avait affirmé que sergue et la
roche avait eu des problèmes cardiaques
il avait été hospitalisés il a démenti
et on a pu le voir Installer vous allez
le voir sur la terrasse de sa chambre
hôtel arborant un t-shirt Basquiat
Serguey lavrois fallait m'accusé les
journalistes occidentaux d'être biaisés
on regarde cette séquence
j'aimerais que les journalistes
occidentaux soient plus honnêtes qui ne
le sont qu'ils écrivent plus souvent la
vérité et qu'il ne limitent pas leur
reportage un seul point de vue qu'il
diffuse sur toute les questions ou sont
impliquées les intérêts russes qui sont
ignorés
le t-shirt ça ne s'invente pas quand
même
à plaisanté en disant mais il peut pas
faire une crise cardiaque il n'a pas de
cœur bon bon c'est intéressant en tout
cas communication classique c'est ce
sont les Occidentaux qui sont fautifs là
oui sur la sur le fond oui sur la forme
pas du tout serguez lavrove qui est
plutôt de l'image du diplomate sobre
très en contrôle
alors je parle sous votre contrôle
peut-être que non mais non moi en tout
cas en T-shirt et en short comme ça je
l'ai pas souvent vu par contre pour moi
l'image de l'isolement de la Russie ou
de la du fait que Vladimir Poutine n'en
est pas c'est cette conférence de presse
qui a donné serguer la broff à l'issue
du G20 où il y avait cinq micros des
chaînes de télévision propagandistes
russes autour de lui en caméra très
serré pour pas justement montrer où il
était devant debout devant un mur sans
son logo derrière sans rien faire on est
quand même loin du représentant d'un
grand pays qui est à égal avec les
autres voilà et c'est vrai que cette
image là c'est ce n'est pas pour
renforcer une image de grandeur de
puissance et de de sérieux que veut
envoyer la Russie aujourd'hui
ça c'est ce grand affirmation de la
journée oui alors vous avez raison parce
qu'il y a une rupture effectivement dans
dans la vocation même des événements
parce que le G20 effectivement une
vocation économique au départ d'ailleurs
c'est en 2017 que j'ai 20 comme ça c'est
intéressé à d'autres pays à autre que
ceux qui composaient donc ce groupe
effectivement une rupture que ce qui
amène d'ailleurs se poser la question et
je dirais sur la nature même sur la
destination du G20 parce que le G20
n'est pas une organisation politique et
ne détient pas une légitimité
particulière c'est-à-dire que la seule
organisation internationale détenant une
légitimité de ce point de vue c'est
l'ONU si le G20 effectivement commence à
faire de la politique vous me direz que
les briques aussi ont essayé un moment
donné de mettre en place un modèle
politique alternatif donc le G20 est
fondé à le faire ceci dit la question de
la légitimité de G20 à résoudre des
conflits majeurs comme ceux dont celui
dont nous parlons pourrait s'opposer à
un moment donné en tant que aujourd'hui
ou pas ça légitimité du G20 justement si
on n'est pas forcément la légitimité du
G20 mais l'espace efficace traiter le
sujet parce que je veux pas évacuer la
légitimité historique et absolument
incontestable de des Nations Unies et en
particulier du Conseil de sécurité mais
force est constaté que à force de veto
et la Russie est tantôt la Chine ont
rendu cet espace relativement limitant
pour pouvoir y parvenir je veux pas dire
qu'il faudrait substituer
le Conseil de sécurité le G20 c'est pas
du tout mon propos ce que je veux dire
c'est que à un moment donné sur un
certain nombre de sujets le trade des
diplomates c'est de trouver l'arène dans
laquelle la meilleure décision peut-elle
fonctionner pour réformer le Conseil de
sécurité
qui est sous-jacentes mais ce qui est ce
qui est intéressant c'est que ça s'est
produit des facto l'Indonésie a tout
fait pour que le G20 ne soit pas le
moment au cours duquel on allait aborder
ces sujets là qui sont d'ordre politique
immunitaire et qui doivent être traités
au conseil de soft c'est ce qui s'est
passé
dans la nature du G20 si j'ose dire
puisque son historique ça a été celui
d'un bloc de gestion de crise c'est à
dire que le G20 c'est l'attrape tout au
moment où il y a une crise et qui a un
G20 c'est cette crise qui devient le le
sommet de la pyramide du G20 donc
l'Indonésie a raté son coup de pas en en
faire une enceinte politique
parce que le G20 globalement c'est ce
que serait un Conseil de sécurité élargi
en réalité ce sont les mêmes
donc si le G20 est capable d'apporter
quelque chose et par la confrontation
non seulement des cinq membres
permanents mais des pays dit émergeant
ça fait longtemps qu'ils ont émergé pour
certains d'entre eux alors il y aura une
piste intéressante je pense pour la
réforme du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies d'ailleurs décidément
d'ailleurs dans cette optique l'Afrique
notamment par la voix de Macky Sall
actuellement exercice de l'Union
africaine demande de l'intégration
d'autres pays africains n'ont pas tous
les pays africains mais ils demandent
pas ils demandent très clairement que
l'Afrique du Sud ne soit pas le seul
pays ne soit plus le seul pays à
représenter le continent africain mais
que l'Union africain en tant quantité
soit considéré comme un membre de G20
km/h effectivement voilà ce qui serait
logique d'ailleurs puisque la question
africaine sont de plus en plus intégrées
dans l'agenda de G20 donc on le disait
en plein sommet du G20 il y a deux
immeubles résidentiels de Kiev qui ont
été touchés par une attaque aux missile
imputée à la Russie donc ça s'est passé
littéralement aujourd'hui pendant le G20
des bombardements qui ont lieu aussi à
vivre donc à l'ouest aussi à carquif et
ce sont vraiment les premières frappes
russes depuis la libération de Carson et
électricité est coupée dans plusieurs
régions en Ukraine on va écouter la
réaction d'une habitante de Kiev et
également les propos de vos diverses qui
ont suivi
mon appartement se trouve à l'opposé de
cette immeuble Mata a sauté sur la table
j'étais à côté
j'ai ressenti l'explosion et après j'ai
vu la fumée j'ai couru jusqu'au balcon
pour voir d'où cela venait au début j'ai
cru que c'était une explosion duo gaz
sur nos villes la plupart sur des
infrastructures énergétiques ce que
l'ennemi veut éclaire mais il
n'atteindra pas son objectif
il a peut-être encore 20 frappes à venir
donc je demande à tout le monde de faire
attention et de rester dans les abris
pour quelques temps encore
de vos hiverski c'était cet après-midi
ce matin il y avait heure française je
parle ce discours au G20 donc sur les 10
conditions justement pour préparer les
pour parler de paix on voit bien tout de
même qu'il y a une dichotomie qu'on est
tout d'un coup à nouveau dans la
violence alors qu'on était dans les
discussions c'est pas facile Vladimir
Poutine lui n'était pas dans les
discussions on Vladimir Poutine et dans
la violence justement je pense que c'est
très emblématique ce qui se passe c'est
à dire que à un moment donné on se
posait la question mais est-ce que
Vladimir Poutine irait au G20 ou pas
pour rencontrer Joe Biden on sait même
poser la question de savoir si cette
fameuse menace nucléaire qu'il
brandissait sans cesse si ce n'était pas
pour un moyen un levier de pression pour
ensuite rencontrer Joe Biden et avoir
une discussion avec celui qui considère
depuis de nombreuses années comme son
véritable interlocuteur dans une guerre
quelle qu'elle soit froide ou chaude etc
en réalité pour pour rejoindre ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure sur le G20 un
espace
j'ai le mot russe un espace politique ou
non je pense que la gravité de ce qui se
passe c'est très banal ce que je dis
mais la gravité de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en Ukraine fait qu'on ne
pouvait pas évacuer la question
ukrainienne du G20 qui n'a pas vocation
à parler de ces questions là à la base
sergueil lavrof a tenté justement et la
Russie tente sans cesse de minimiser
cette question de reléguer ce conflit
comme comme une guerre existentielle
naturelle que devrait mener la Russie
sur fond de un tas d'autres problèmes
beaucoup plus internationaux finalement
beaucoup plus important dont de vrais
s'occuper le monde au lieu de s'occuper
de ce qui se passe en Ukraine et de sa
petite tentative d'invasion qui n'en est
pas une et dans son mot dans sa Parole
introductive de sa conférence de presse
avant que les journalistes ne lui posent
la question il a parlé pendant une
dizaine de minutes de covid en fait il
n'a pas prononcé le mot Ukraine il n'a
pas abordé cette question et ce sont
même les journalistes même russes qui
l'ont qui l'ont ramené à ce thème donc
on voit que il y a deux espaces il y a
l'espace de la communauté internationale
et des pays membres du G20 en tout cas
ou du G19 pour qui cette question
aujourd'hui l'ampleur de cette invasion
est aussi les événements qui se passent
avec le retrait russe de Carson
c'est-à-dire qu'on est aujourd'hui à se
demander est-ce que la Russie ne va pas
finalement perdre cette guerre cette
question et apprend tellement d'ampleur
que finalement c'est naturel Vladimir
Poutine lui reste dans sa rhétorique qui
pour rejoindre encore une fois ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure on est une pas
celle de la négociation elle est celle
de la violence pure et simple pour vous
qui êtes le diplomate c'est frappe
aujourd'hui les premières après la
reprise de Carson par les Ukrainiens en
plein G20 ce n'est pas hasard non sur TF
en particulier
je pense qu'on doit s'interroger
aujourd'hui sur le rôle de Vladimir
Poutine je pense que Vladimir Poutine
comme au début de l'épisode du covid
souvenez-vous il a disparu purement et
simplement dans sa ville là à Sotchi
après avoir délégué les responsabilités
au gouverneur et aux entreprises a
disparu il a délégué aux militaires il a
délégué la guerre aux militaire c'est ce
qui s'est passé à Carson alors ce schéma
les militaires font la guerre je fais la
diplomatie tenait mais sauf qu'il n'est
pas allé à excusez-moi à Bali au G20
donc moi je pense qu'il faut se poser la
question de savoir si ce ne sont pas de
fait les militaires et j'ai envie de
dire l'extrême droite nationaliste qui
pointe le nez derrière Vladimir Poutine
vous avez entendu cette phrase
extraordinaire de dogging le théologien
c'est le cas de le dire de la suprématie
du monde continental lundi ce matin je
crois il faut assassiner Poutine il nous
mène de défaite en défaite c'était le
théoricien de Vladimir Poutine donc la
question qu'on peut se poser aujourd'hui
c'est de savoir si ce ne sont pas les
militaires qui de leur propre chef ont
envoyé ses missiles sur un certain
nombre de villes je ne sais pas je ne
l'ordre de Poutine moi peut-être Elena
on sait plus que moi je que fait Poutine
depuis trois ou quatre jours que fait
Poutine depuis l'annonce du retrait de
de Carson personne n'en sait rien
personne pour lesquelles on a qui
explique son absence au G20 c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a eu véritablement une question
de pourquoi est-ce qu'il ne s'est pas
rendu sur place
et un des éléments de réponse qui a été
avancé c'est gérer la pression politique
intérieure c'est-à-dire je suis parti du
pays survivre je suis moins insécurité
et
Moscou est un peu plus libre d'agir en
mon absence à mon retour ça sera plus
difficile donc je crois que derrière les
propos de Jean-Marie perd sans wish full
thinking de changement de régime qui
pourrait faciliter l'issue de la guerre
en Ukraine ou pas d'ailleurs il y a
quand même la question qui se pose pour
Poutine de la stabilité de son régime à
l'heure où les défaites s'enchaînent la
première c'était le régime challenge sur
Kiev qui a été un échec monumental la
deuxième c'était la guerre d'annexion
qui s'est assez vite enlisée les
contrefensives Ukrainiennes qui l'ont
fait perdre des batailles extrêmement
symboliques enfin la reprise de cariffe
en quelques semaines alors que la
bataille de cvordoniens ce qui a duré
beaucoup plus longtemps c'était c'était
un coup très très dur à encaisser et
maintenant la reprise de Carson malgré
le changement des états majors du
commandement de l'opération militaire
spéciale avec l'installation générale
sur Vikings ne retient pas il doit
encaisser ces chocs là et ça provoque
des des des éléments de stabilité
politique d'instabilité qui peuvent
expliquer aussi son absence à Bali
la question il y a une grande solitude
de la nuit Poutine à présent parce que
si on voilà si on observe les propos et
les signaux qui va bien Poutine n'a pas
à multiplié au cours des dernières
années au cours des cinq dix dernières
années et que cette croisade contre
l'Occident dont ils se réclame
aujourd'hui il espérait prendre la tête
de cette croisade avec derrière lui je
dirais des alliés
il espérant en tout cas être à la tête
de une sorte de de front en fait de
front antioxydantal composé de multiples
alliés aussi bien en Asie que en Afrique
or aujourd'hui on va bien la distance la
distance peut-être sous une forme de
neutralité que prennent tous les pays
dessus lesquels ils comptaient pour
soutenir cette action là ça nous amène
juste pour en quelques mots
observer de plus près les objectifs de
la guerre parce que pour qu'il y ait des
soutiens il faut que ces objectifs de la
guerre soit tout à fait clair on est
parti d'une probable des nazifications
de l'Ukraine aujourd'hui une forme que
moi de désatanisation puisque de
l'Occident en fait on en est là on avait
parlé d'une opération spéciale et Claire
qui aurait dû jouer quelques jours ou
quelques semaines à peine on en est au
10e mois et je me demande même si
Poutine lui-même a une idée claire
aujourd'hui de ce pourquoi il a envoyé
je dirais pourquoi il s'est engagé dans
cette entreprise qui est au fond et ça
c'est une réalité qui reste une
entreprise de nature impérialiste alors
on va revenir sur les séquelles de
l'occupation en russe à Carson Carson
donc qui a été reprise par les
Ukrainiens le weekend dernier avec Laura
combo
après la libération de Carson les
habitants arrachent tous les panneaux et
bannières prorus installés dans la ville
il n'y avait plus de panneaux
publicitaires que de la propagande russe
partout ça me dégoûte
se débarrasser à tout prix de ces
messages pour lutter contre les
traumatismes occasionnés par huit mois
d'occupation russe on rêvait de ce
moment je n'y crois toujours pas j'ai
toujours cette peur de marcher dans la
rue je regarde autour de moi qui est
derrière moi tout le temps angoisse
stress nervosité les séquelles sur les
habitants sont nombreuses en pleine
célébration ils échangent leur récit
c'était effrayant des connaissances ont
été emmenés par les Russes elles sont
revenues deux semaines plus tard sans
dents et avec des reins endommagés dans
cette prison aussi les détenus n'ont pas
été épargnés bien au contraire il
décrivent des conditions de vie terrible
et une violence sinouïe
le premier jour où les Russes sont
entrés dans la prison ils ont commencé à
tirer et à lancer des grenades beaucoup
de mes amis n'ont pas survécu
ils ont tiré sur certains d'entre eux à
deux reprises j'ai été emmené dehors
pour être exécuté par miracle ils ne
m'ont pas tué des observateurs de l'ONU
ont documenté des exécutions sommaires
il compte déjà entre 77 et 84 de
disparition forcées et de détention
arbitraire dans la région une nouvelle
équipe doit venir à Carson pour enquêter
elle pourrait découvrir des charniers à
l'image de se trouver à izum après la
Libération
Helena voulait peut-être commenter
justement on voit bien qu'il y a des
crimes de guerre qui ont été commis par
les Russes finalement cette reprise de
Carson ressemble un petit peu à ce qui a
pu se passer à carquif ou dans d'autres
villes
ukrainiennes oui complètement ma
collègue mentionné yum à la sortie du
sujet j'y étais et c'est exactement les
mêmes témoignages vous n'avez pas une
personne à la sortie des aporisia aussi
il n'y a pas une personne
qui ne raconte des cas de torture
d'exaction d'enlèvement c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment stupéfiant c'est à dire
qu'on s'attendait à ce qu'il y ait des
des
exactions mais de l'ordre de
l'arbitraire ou ou de cas isolés là
c'est on est dans un régime dehors
systématique installé dans dans ces
territoires occupés mon collègue
Gulliver crack encore envoyé un
reportage aussi depuis bahlakia la
région de kerkiff c'est pareil tout le
monde raconte ses enlèvements se
détention arbitraires alors ça peut être
parce que vous sortez après après le
couvre-feu ou que vous vous avez bu de
l'alcool
pour des choses du quotidien comme ça
tout comme ça peut être pour des raisons
purement politique ou politique supposée
c'est-à-dire que on ne vous soupçonne à
peine d'être soit un Patriot ukrainien
soit d'avoir posté des postes sur les
réseaux pro Ukrainiens sur les réseaux
sociaux ou d'avoir d'une quelconque
façon aider l'effort de guerre côté
ukrainien par exemple j'ai moi j'ai
interviewé un garde forestier qui a été
torturé parce qu'on avait trouvé cette
tenue de camouflage chez lui alors que
c'est une tenue qu'il porte pour son
travail de garde forestier vous voyez
donc on en est là on est dans dans des
des cas où les militaires ont les mains
complètement déliés en fait pour
torturer pour enlever pour détenir la
population et apparemment c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui relève de du système
et de quelque chose de systématique dans
certaines il faudra sur les crèmes de
guerre il faudra effectivement que la
lumière Poutine que la Russie paye pour
ses crimes ça sera
demandé la mise en place d'un tribunal
spécial je préside aussi une ONG qui
s'occupe d'enfants plan international et
nous savons que non seulement des
enfants sont enlevés mais comme vous le
savez ils sont déportés en Russie
notamment en Extrême-Orient et donner à
des familles comme le faisait les
dictateurs argentins avec les enfants de
ceux qu'il jetaient d'hélicoptère dans
la mer on donne des enfants Ukrainiens à
des familles russes on connaît les
exactions commises par le groupe Wagner
et on sait aussi comment ils se sont
comportés au Mali en Centrafrique en
Syrie et aujourd'hui en Ukraine ce sont
des gens qui violent qui tuent qui
piquent assassine il faut vraiment
savoir de quoi on parle il y a des
dizaines de milliers de victimes civiles
depuis le début de la guerre en Ukraine
qui sont assassinés par ces gens enfin
en revenir justement au G20 Francis la
loupeaux il est question que le projet
de communiquer mentionne le mot guerre
en Ukraine alors que on sait que Moscou
parle toujours donc d'opérations
spéciales est-ce qu'il pourrait y avoir
ça serait peut-être quelque chose de
très important un G20 qui se termine
avec un communiqué qui mentionne la
guerre en Ukraine parce que je pense que
ceux qui sont à Bali ceux qui sont
moins de ceci en commun désormais c'est
le front qui condamnent très clairement
l'invasion de la Russie de l'Ukraine par
la Russie ou qui en tout cas manifeste
une forme de distance vis-à-vis de
Poutine je pense au président chinois
par exemple donc il n'est pas impossible
que en arriver qu'on parle de guerre de
toute façon dans les coulisses c'est le
mot guerre qui est employé sur personne
on parle d'opération spéciale alors
cette semaine a dit que finalement cette
ce conflit
il faut nommer la situation pour ce
qu'elle est il s'agit d'une guerre vous
pouvez trouver des solutions puisqu'on
parle de négociations possibles on a
ensuite trouvé les voies moyen d'une
médiation et ensuite d'une résolution
des conflits oh il sera très difficile
de résoudre un conflit et je reviens à
ce que je disais tout à l'heure donc on
ne connaît pas la véritable nature au
fond les objectifs parce que d'abord il
faut nommer le conflit et ensuite
repréciser les objectifs pour lesquels
un pays a décidé d'envahir un autre et
on mépris de ses frontières on mépris de
l'intensité des front et du respect de
l'intégrité territoriale d'un pays tant
que je pense que ces critère ne seront
pas posés ces paramètres ne sont pas
admis de tous il va être difficile de
trouver les voies et moyens de la
résolution de ce conflit encore faut-il
savoir si la Russie veut jouer le jeu de
la résolution du conflit conformément au
droit international puisque depuis
quelques temps on entend quand même de
plus en plus les dirigeants russes
politiques russes dit suggérer
d'ailleurs que la Russie se retire en
fait du contexte actuel de relations
internationales donc créer une sorte je
dirais de Paul autre que celui qui
aujourd'hui régit les relations
internationales c'est-à-dire les Nations
Unies alors on a des sortes de groupe
alternatifs
à une forme je dirais de l'estravagance
juridique puisque la Russie la question
se pose clairement aujourd'hui de savoir
si la Russie fait partie toujours de
cette communauté internationale
j'entends bien compte international par
la communauté qui fonde et constitue la
nation la Nation Unies d'où la question
aussi de savoir si
le Conseil de sécurité tel qu'il
fonctionne aujourd'hui est encore valide
parce que pour l'instant ils ont un
siège aux Nations unies au Conseil de
sécurité il l'utilisent très souvent
Thomas friand est-ce qu'il pourrait y
avoir effectivement un communiqué du G20
qui cite cette guerre en Ukraine alors
je cette question du communiqué par
symbolique parce qu'il s'agit d'un
élément déclaratif qui n'est pas
politiquement pas juridiquement
engageant il ne l'est que politiquement
mais en réalité tout est derrière cette
question parce que s'il y a un
communiqué qui ne mentionne pas le mot
guerre qui mentionne tous les à côté
c'est une victoire russe énorme s'il y a
un communiqué qui mentionne le mot
guerre
ça sera probablement à communiquer du
G19 et ça sera donc l'acte de mort du
G20 ou en tout cas la recomposition
d'autre chose et qui signalera d'une
manière ou d'une autre qu'à un moment ou
un autre se posera la question la
légitimité de la place de la Russie en
tant que membre permanent du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies donc ça
condamne la mort le G20 finalement en
tant que tel non ça va remettre en cause
sa composition et la composition du G20
est très intéressante parce qu'en fait
on parle de G20 comme s'il y avait 20
personnes autour de la table il y en a
41 donc cette question là est un petit
peu plus complexe si il y a un
communiqué qui qui ne mentionne pas le
la guerre en Ukraine mais qui se
contente de mentionner les conséquences
et la façon dont donc évidemment je
parlais tout à l'heure de l'inflation
l'énergie des questions de santé etc et
qui parle seulement du conflit
et bien je crois que ça sera une forme
d'échec occidental et ça traduira quoi
ça traduira le fait que l'échec que
l'Occident pardon aura en tout cas
transigé pour faire prévaloir son désir
son appétit pour le multilatéralisme
plutôt que sur la tension c'est pas
forcément ce qu'il y a de plus évident
il me semble que ce qu'il y a de plus
probable puisque la présence
indonésienne nous y a préparé c'est
qu'il n'y ait pas de communiquer du tout
ce qui serait là aussi une rupture dans
l'histoire du G20 puisque ça ne s'est
jamais produit ça ne s'est produit
qu'une seule fois dans l'histoire du G7
donc au moment de Charlevoix 2018 où le
les États du G7 se réunissent se mettent
d'accord il y a quelques dissensus sur
les questions de commerce international
Trump est vexé par Trudeau et dans
l'avion il dit les États-Unis se
retirent de de ce communiqué et c'est la
seule fois dans l'histoire de ces
groupes où il n'y a rien eu de forme de
consensus donc peut-être je pense que
communiquer du tout
la présidence indonésienne a annoncé
l'idée selon laquelle on pourrait avoir
un G20 qui débouche sur rien comme si
c'était un G7 éviter finalement le sujet
j'ai cru comprendre ce que j'ai eu de
certaines sources et en écoutant la brof
aussi qu'il y aura un communiqué où il
sera question de la guerre en Ukraine
mais la façon de ménager la Russie qui
parle aussi de guerre en Ukraine et qui
parle de guerre que mènerait les
Occidentaux contre la Russie en Ukraine
serait de dire guerre en Ukraine mais
pas guerre de la Russie en Ukraine et
Serge tout à l'heure dans sa conférence
de presse disait que il y avait vécu
apparemment un accord sur un communiqué
et que la Russie avait obtenu que soit
mentionné dans cette dans ce communiqué
final le fait que des versions
alternatives à la version principale ont
été prononcées lors du G20 ça c'est très
intéressant parce que il y a une
technique de parade qui sont alternative
de qui n'est pas la fake news mais qui
est la déclaration interprétative du
communiqué c'est-à-dire qu'il existe des
moments dans les sommets du G20 ou du G7
ou le G20 produit son communiqué avec
des mots un peu alambiqué pour mettre
tout le monde d'accord et où l'État qui
est mal à l'aise du fait de la
Déclaration fait sa propre déclaration
pour expliquer comment lui il interprète
les termes du communiqué et c'est un peu
cette logique là qui a présenté votre
journaliste en disant ben la Russie
pourrait expliquer que de
autrement dit il s'est passé quoi aussi
d'autres choses à ce jeu absolument le
G20 ne produit pas que le communiqué il
y a je pense que ce qui est le plus
intéressant à suivre ce sont les
réunions bilatérales qui ont lieu à
l'occasion
elle-même d'autres communiqués qui sont
aussi importants que le communiqué du
groupe alors il y a une réunion
intéressante aujourd'hui entre Emmanuel
Macron la Scholl ours sous la forme de
layonne Macky Sall Paul Kagame ses pays
d'Afrique ont justement évoqué la
famille les risques de famine et puis
cet accord sur les céréales qui a permis
de livrer 10 millions de tonnes de
céréales à l'Ukraine un accord donc qui
doit se terminer vendredi et Emmanuel
Macron a tweeté on va regarder le tweet
du président français la Turquie et la
France continueront de vrai pour que les
exportations de céréales ukrainiennes se
poursuivent sans entrave afin de limiter
le risque de famine dans le monde est-ce
qu'effectivement ce G20 pourrait se
terminer par une prolongation de cette
décor de cet accord Francis laupo est-ce
que d'un point de vue voilà de ce côté
là ça pourrait marcher
oui ça pourrait marcher dans la mesure
où c'est un c'est une forme de renfort
que je vais apporter au pays au pays
africains qui ont quand même le dire
sont les premiers victimes de cette
crise alors que ce sont les pays les
plus éloignés du théâtre du conflit quoi
et donc je pense que ce soutien de très
important mais au-delà de ce soutien si
le plan évidemment des céréales la
question alimentaire il y a aussi la
question climatique des financement
quand même climatique sont aussi au
coeur au cas de discussion la question
de la dette également parce que les GB
avait apporté
en particulier
les plus fragiles en tout cas voilà donc
il y a un certain nombre de sujets qui
constituent en fait le menu de
discussion entre ces entre les autres
Africains Macky Sall à époque la gamme
et le G20 mais ce que réclame
aujourd'hui Macky Sall et c'est un
émissaire pense certaines émissaire de
continent de ce point de vue là c'est
que au-delà de cette discussion
ponctuelles au-delà de ce qui peut
constituer l'aide à portée par le G20 il
faut peut-être dépasser la notion de
l'aide et
amener en fait mais mettre en place les
mécanismes permettant l'Afrique de
devenir un partenaire à part entière du
G20 y compris peut-être même peut-être
même d'ailleurs au-delà même des
partenariats un membre à part entière de
G20
ce n'est pas très compliqué je veux
d'intégrer l'Union africaine en tant
quantité unique où j'ai vu comme l'Union
européenne est un membre en tant
quantité en tant quantité du G20 n'est
pas impossible parce que politiquement
c'est ainsi que se dessine peut-être
aussi le schéma de l'avenir ça pourrait
être ce que Emmanuel Macron appelle le
multirate le multilatéralisme efficace
Thomas friand improbable d'ailleurs ça
se ritualise sans forcément que ça soit
verbalisé c'est à dire que la présidence
de l'Union africaine
occupée par le Sénégal cette année et
une forme d'invité permanent le G20 à
nouveau c'est le chiffre est trompeur
parce que prenez l'exemple de l'Espagne
l'Espagne n'est pas membre du bien c'est
un invité permanent la présidence a par
exemple le droit c'est une sorte de
tradition dans le G20 d'inviter cinq
pays dont elle considère que pour son
rayonnement régional et pour les
politiques les problèmes politiques à la
résoudre elle a le droit d'inviter ses
pays c'est assez un choix souverain par
exemple
l'Indonésie a choisi d'inviter le
Suriname le Cambodge Singapour etc donc
c'est assez le G20 n'étant pas une
institution est assez plastique pour
aller dans sa direction je crois que
cette direction est déjà prise si
c'était formalisé validé entériné
politiquement par l'ensemble des membres
ça serait encore mieux parce que ça
donnerait une place significative à
l'Union africaine on peut que le
souhaiter maintenant la suite il faut
pas être naïf la situation extrêmement
dégradée de la coopération
internationale n'est pas un moment dans
lequel des grands consensus comme ça se
forgent aujourd'hui c'est c'est un peu
regrettable vous vous rappelez
comme objectif la construction d'une
union économique sur le même modèle que
l'Union européenne donc elle est
parfaitement légitime demander son
intégration donc le
multilatéralisme efficace pardon c'est
la bonne expression vous pensez Jean
Maurice repair merci beaucoup Elena
d'avoir été avec nous Elena Volochine
Merci à VOUS Jean-Maurice Ripert merci
Thomas friand Merci à VOUS Francis
laloupeaux et merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis et vous restez avec nous
sur France 24
[Musique]